this is what's left of the Mason Dixon
line that separates North and South here
it's how division looks we crossed it to
gauge how it
feels after a weekend of a president his
infection and a prognosis trapped in a
pressure
leas a mile into Pennsylvania they're
swinging in the swing state cutting corn
and preparing pumpkins for Halloween
these are uh Swan gourds un how did the
president's performance go down here
this is a or treat all he's worried
about his his being reelected his ego
what's best for him not for the people I
want someone that's for the people show
them what's up show the town of New
Freedom is in York County which heavily
backed Donald Trump in the last election
it's a town in a count
in a state that's critical to an
election win I spoke to neighbors Peggy
and Gary friends if not political
soulmates you might not agree with it
but he he is a
Hands-On uh crowd pleasing person and
that that that didn't surprise me a bit
this tips of scales in so far as I've
got you know here a a
77 74 y old man um who is
ill um I I don't know that I would vote
for him who who is ill I would say of
his own because of his own actions
opinion polls indicate most Americans
think the president wouldn't have caught
Co if he'd taken it more
seriously and the majority say they
think he hasn't been telling the truth
about the
virus it doesn't derail the Trump
campaign but it doesn't necessarily help
it it's long been focused on the ABC of
election campaigning anything but Co
right now it's About Little
Else in Marlin's Auto Center downtown
they've seen a growth in business in the
Trump era it's important to not have a
weak leader um but the other half of it
is that I don't think downplaying it is
valuable because that's the kind of
thing that leads to recklessness why am
I racing the public response matter to
Donald Trump he's been consistently
behind in the polls and doesn't need the
fresh hit James Matthews Sky News
Pennsylvania